yeah so let me just let you guys uh uh
know
basically what happened so we were we
were trying to figure out and we're
still trying to figure out good shows to
do
that are kind of
unique we had vosh and charlie kirk and
i thought that was great
it was kind of crossfirey like the left
versus the right nah and it's kind of a
little too on the nose so we're trying
to figure out interesting personalities
that may agree or disagree but not be in
the same spaces in the culture war so
maybe someone who's a comedian versus
you know having a discussion with
somebody who's in finance or getting
someone like you know max keiser who's a
bitcoin guy to sit down and talk about
someone who's all into philosophy
originally we had reached out to shu on
head who was a big youtuber and she was
super excited that she wanted to do it
and after we confirmed with her we went
to alex and we were like hey alex you
know she was agreed to do the show would
you be willing to do it and uh
alex we were trying to work on your
schedule figure out a date and then once
we finally confirmed alex's availability
she would had unfortunately said that
she didn't think she'd be able to do it
she didn't know what she could add to
the show and it's a bummer because i
think it would have been a really really
really great show and she was really
just afraid to get cancelled if she was
even close to me which again whatever
happened in america we're not the soviet
union
it's good to come on if you disagree
with somebody and have a debate with
them that's what's interesting that's
what everybody's looking for that's why
crossfire used to have 15 million
viewers and now it doesn't exist they
have no viewers at cnn is because it's
all just orthodoxy
the same gaslighting brainwashing i
don't care if it's right-wing or
left-wing no one wants that plus
you said before we went live and i think
it's true i think she was scared as a
populace she'd probably agree with me
and that's when she'd get in trouble
because you have the character of alex
they put out which is little snippets
out of context versus the real one yeah
so uh basically we were talking before
the show and you know i'm just gonna
shout you out ian ian was like we
shouldn't bring it up we don't want to
be disrespectful
and i i i can see with that because i i
think i think shawn has great i think
her channel hey i don't blame her
there's a lot of charity out there and
and so you know keeping your head down
might be what you want to do but when
everybody does that you lose your
country and you wake up in north korea
like i was saying earlier that alex and
shu are a perfect fit together because
shu's entire persona and everything is
built on memes on the internet and and
there's like alex is one of the most
prolific meme creators of of the 21st
century so it's a for her to back out
just doesn't make any sense for her
brand or for you know aside from the
fact that she might get pushed back from
some of her more left leaning friends so
this is where i i ended up you know i
think she's incredibly talented and
funny which is why she has the million
plus or half you know you know all the
fans she has the million plus views she
gets on all her videos
and you know perhaps she's i don't wanna
i don't wanna call her liar or anything
when she says she doesn't think she'd
have much to add and she feel like she
wouldn't be participating enough i mean
i think it's a fair point perhaps but i
think she underestimates herself and
then i also think a big component is
we've had steve bannon on the show and
steve bannon talked a lot about populism
and he calls himself far right but then
he says he wants to tax the rich and i'm
like that's not far right steve yeah i
don't think any of the labels i mean we
need populism we need americanism and
that's classical liberalism the left is
not liberalism people study it it goes
back to the jacobins and the french
revolution and george washington said
that is not who we are that's the enemy
they were gonna have nine day work weeks
abolish the family make everybody slaves
it was getting rid of the church and the
oligarchy and the royalty and creating a
total system of control so the left
literally comes out of a super insane uh
cult which was the real illuminati adam
vice officers and mainline history books
and and they set up the french
revolution we're gonna set themselves up
as god so they would have all the
science everybody else would be like
animal slaves and out of that came
communism did it seem like i don't know
about i don't know about it did it seem
like the french revolution got
infiltrated well let me that's why yeah
i want to address it they tried to kill
thomas jefferson
he was a leader of the illuminati at
that point and and and then he had to
get he had to get out yes
yes
why it's so early in the conference yes
you know this is well this is well known
george washington this is what i'm here
for george washington wrote
16 letters you can pull them up george
washington wrote 16 letters against the
illuminati he said they've taken over
the french they've taken over modern
masonry and i'm trying to stop them our
revolution is is the one that's good and
pure and and theirs is destructive and
he told jefferson you're gonna
once he wasn't president they're gonna
try to kill you and they later turned on
jefferson because i mean you know that
benjamin franklin was not a christian he
was in the hellfire club had big sex
orgies the rest of it and uh
why is this true i felt like i felt like
from the library of congress oh no
they found like 30 dead kids under his
house okay alex jones is never wrong
hold on hold on
i wanted to say something first
that you brought up a point about
something i said about shu that you'd
say something populist that she would
agree with and that would be bad for a
lot of these people who are scared of
being cancelled to have a clip where you
know alex jones says something about
protecting the working class and this
country and fighting for families and
then having someone who spoke to the
left being like you're completely right
alex jones then having that clip go out
is bad for somebody who's on the left
right that's that's the point now then
you got into the illuminati and thomas
jefferson i don't even know where we're
at but
awesome
wait wait wait hold on hold on
so i googled it
uh i'm at the library of congress
and there is a it says manuscript mixed
material and there's a picture here of a
letter to reverend g w snyder mount
vernon september 25th 1798. george
street down the street george washington
george washington to william russell i
uh he said i have heard much of the
nefarious and dangerous plan and
doctrines of the illuminati but never
saw the book until you were pleased to
send it to me
the same causes which have prevented my
acknowledging the receipt of your letter
have prevented my reading the book
hitherto namely the the multiplicity of
matters which pressed upon me before and
the debilitated debilitated state in
which i was left after a severe fever
had been removed and which allows me to
add a little more now then thanks to
your kind wishes and favorable
sentiments except to correct an error
you have run into of my presiding over
the english lodges in this country the
fact is i preside over none nor have i
been in one more than once or twice
within the last 30 years i believe
notwithstanding that none of the lodges
in this country are contaminated with
the principles ascribed to the society
of the illuminati
so there there's more
the point is wow frederick maryland oh
hey yeah amazing
he's talking about mason lodges
all i know is all i want to say is
george washington did write letters to
william russell about the illuminati i
don't know if that means thomas
jefferson was read all 16. i mean thomas
jefferson was the head of the illuminati
that's well known before that franklin
was but they were the head of the good
illuminati then you had adam vicep and
his jacobins take over the illuminati
illuminati just meant elimination and
light and then and they wanted to
control the light maybe this is why she
didn't want to come out my mind is blown
this is amazing alex jones is never
wrong
but i'm never wrong intentionally but i
mean this stuff's mainline history it's
just not really taught in schools but
i've read a bunch of books on it uh that
are like written hundreds like done like
um proofs of this conspiracy
and it was that book that basically out
of that they had the whole anti-masonic
uh
party and stuff which i'm not
anti-masonic i mean that's way more comp
that goes back to solomon and egypt and
back then the colleges were secret you
just let anybody in they were called the
mystery schools so it had like the
birthplace of astronomy and science and
medicine and all that goes back to
hippocrates and all that so there's
these mystery schools that only certain
people can get into and then it also has
a backdrop of the occult and then
christians and people saw it as all
satanic which it wasn't uh because it
all predates
society
i don't want to this is a really really
deep subject and maybe people might be
disappointed because i didn't intend to
go off in that direction we were
originally talking about the left and
not wanting to come in how did we get
there because the left is the french
revolution
to like rebuild and take care of poor
people and give them actually jobs and
and care about our pop that's more
liberal than leftists that work for big
corporations and hide behind blm but
really don't care about the general
public and help big tech build slave
camps in china left is not inherently
liberal right right so
what i wanted to say was
we reached out to a bunch of people on
the left
and they were very respectful in
declining to come on the show
i think it's because
you mentioned cancel culture that's kind
of what they say to me they're like
there's there's no upside for for this
if i do this it's just
bad for me right they could sit down
have a conversation with you they could
sit down have a conversation with steve
bannon in fact what i want to say was
when we had bennett on the show people
commented wow
i the media made it sound like he's
crazy but he's actually like a normal
guy very well spoken
yeah but you you you know the the
the study that uh they study the people
that consider themselves liberal in the
u.s compared to conservatives and and
conservatives understand the liberals
and just disagree liberals don't
understand conservatives and people that
aren't liberal so right and by liberal
and they don't want to understand them
yeah
they believe a character of them they
believe
they believe that like
the every
ugly character that you come up with
about conservatives that's what the
liberals believe about conservatives and
that's not the case can i just shout out
one of the most frustrating things was
seeing people play the clip of the gay
frogs thing
without without and they were laughing
at you like you were insane when it was
clear you were exaggerating
a real study about atrazine exactly i
just i mean that's like 10 years ago now
i just read
it
memory i i i just wrote an article about
it i think it was like a uh
what's that show it's not pbs democracy
now yeah democracy now had just had the
doctor on it's like 10 years ago about
atrazine the study and how it made the
males attracted to the males so they
didn't have any eggs so they were dying
out right and it was happening all over
the world with with addressing this
toxic and it was hurting humans as well
studies were showing and very
carcinogenic so i said see i just don't
want them putting things in the water
that make the friggin frogs gay and i
said i'm not against gay people i just
don't want to put these up in the water
that makes the frogs gay it's kind of a
joke at the end and then they just went
crazy with that well so turning the
frogs gay well so here's what happens i
see a bunch of posts online where
they're like i can't believe he's crazy
the crazy thing is on reddit you'll see
people actually trying to correct people
like i get it alex jones is crazy but
he's he's not rock he's exaggerating but
look at the study and then the people
are like ah get out of here you nut you
conspiracy theorist i will say though
you're talking i i believe uh updated
studies they followed through found it's
substantially less pronounced or not
happening i don't know the full details
i remember looking into it well let me
give you an example
you're talking about a species that goes
through metamorphosis as part of its
life cycle so influence from from the
environment and from things that aren't
supposed to be there it's it's
completely reasonable to think that
chemicals would have an influence on a
creature that
has so much
that changes so much throughout its life
and you know it it's not that much
when you actually stop and think about
it well also i'm pretty sure aren't
there some species of frog that can
change gender yes i believe yeah so that
birds do it too but but what he just
said is absolutely right because
when they're trying in science to figure
out how to regenerate cells they look at
lizards their tail gets bit off by a
bird it grows back they look at frogs
but we have a little lake on my dad's
ranch in east texas
and he went like a couple years ago to
the to the state and you get carp uh
that have had a chemical put in when
they were eggs and just a few drops of
at the state level makes these big giant
you know carp but they're sterile
uh just from a few drops of a chemical
when they are uh eggs and so that's
that's exactly what he's talking about
so this is wild just i want you you know
just just pause and reflect on the
moment um
you know we were we were just going to
talk about how we originally planned on
doing the show with someone on the left
and then within like 30 seconds it was
thomas jefferson was the leader of the
illuminati i got to find out if
robespierre is amazing did they get to
robespierre or was he actually crazy
do you know much about where did the
illuminati put robespierre in the french
revolution is he there and they co-opted
him like what because he went haywire
they knew they knew a revolution was
coming
and so adam vicep with another group of
people basically infiltrated the masonic
lodges and and got control of some of
the european ones tried to control the
u.s ones and then washington came and
spoke out against them and exposed them
but but it was basically before they had
intelligence agencies they had secret
societies and all that was was then the
secret societies got taken over by the
illuminati who said the royalties weak
the church is weak let's overthrow them
and then we'll infiltrate and basically
get all the nobles to join us and a
bunch of the rich people because we'll
have sex parties and supply them with
prostitutes and and and money as well
because there's a bunch of rich people
backing it thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time